un parcours de 2 destinée exceptionnelle
d'un homme noir qui vit en pleine
période esclavagiste en italie et
puisqu'il est né en 1526 sait qu'il va
mourir en 1589 et que tous les italiens
appellent ils sonnent tomorrow le saint
maur le seynois re lesaint c'est à dire
qu'il a eu une
une trajectoire de vie absolument
remarquable et il a été canonisé
c'est le premier sa noire canonisé par
l'église donc il a été reconnu par
l'église
il a été d'abord béatifié et ensuite
canonisé alors c'est c'est quand même
une une figure une figure de sainteté
pour arriver à la femme moderne qui et
michelle obama qui est arrivé au degré
le plus important au niveau du pouvoir
dans aussi une amérique raciste
donc vous voyez c'est ça c'est ce que
j'ai voulu dire en passant bien sûr par
mus par moi même par des moments de ma
vie
par mon parcours qui a été difficile qui
a été chaotique qui a été celui que
vient dé martinique et connaissent d'une
présentatrice de télévision qui toujours
se heurter au plafond de verre mais des
deux côtés
c'est à dire aussi bien métropole qui si
on n'arrive pas à avoir la carrière pour
laquelle nous sommes fait parce que on
ne donne pas les rôles on ne nous écoute
pas et
et les choses sont difficiles quand on à
l'envi l'ambition la force de le faire
on trouve des barrages de toutes sortes
et c'est ça que j'ai voulu faire éclater
ce plafond de verre j'ai voulu le faire
éclater ce combat se poursuit toujours
depuis à dieu depuis bon sens fait de
doux rêveurs
ah oui oui continua c'est mon troisième
livre et je prépare un quatrième